all right well i apologize to everybody
who has an allergy to high levels of
cringe but we do have to talk about cpac
over the weekend we are going to look at
some of the wackiest moments from cpac
we're going to look at um the various
speakers we'll look at the interviews
that donald trump gave before and after
his cpac speech but we're going to start
with donald trump's completely deranged
unhinged
yes febrile it's the last day of
february so it's the
i'll move on to a different adjective in
march but for february these are still
going to be described as febrile
speeches
donald trump uh at moments the crowd was
engaged at moments the crowd was
completely bored but
apparently announcing a 2024 run by all
estimations trump is saying
he's running in 2024. take a listen
they're going to find out the hard way
starting on november 8th
and then again even more so on
november 2024
they will find out like never before
we did it twice
and we'll do it again we're going to be
doing it again
so this
seems as though it is donald trump
announcing that he is running for
president in 2024 all right are we i
know it's not a formal announcement and
a formal announcement would bring with
it different sorts of limitations and
financial requirements and reporting and
things with trump wants to avoid but it
seems that he's saying he's going to run
um trump kind of bringing out all the
hits that we became used to during his
presidency one is those sort of weird
some people call them like neurological
glitches it's where trump messes up a
word and sort of twitches and it's weird
let's take a look at one of those there
were a handful system to persecute you
you it is a persecution and and again we
don't know what that is it comes there's
a there's a twitch
and he messes up a word and then tries
to get back on track we we we just don't
know what this is we'll look and you
really have to see it let's look at it
once more system to persecute you you is
a person yeah we don't know we we just
we don't know what that is um another
classic from trump is uh the sir
routines stories where trump uses the
word sir are almost always stories that
didn't happen sir sure yeah so here's
trump telling one of his sir stories
i've had great people come up to me and
tell me sir ma'am please ask you a
question
yes what would you like to know sir
how did you take it how did you take it
multiple sirs there and that story
almost certainly didn't happen trump
shouting out his former doctor who's now
a congressman a congressman
and talking about how the doctor got to
know every inch of trump
a man that knows me almost better than
any human being
he knows every inch of me
and he thinks it's actually a very
beautiful sight so just
very weird i mean i i can't say that
that's not funny but it's just all
pretty weird donald trump then seemingly
tries to take credit for getting the
united states out of iraq and out of
afghanistan neither of which happened
while trump was president i mean i don't
know that it matters to him but those
things didn't happen while he was
president remember though
when so many people in the democrat
party and during the debates
said he's going to get us into the third
world war with trump i'm the one that
didn't have any wars i'm the one
that got us out of wars look at iraq
look at syria i was the one that brought
us way down
in afghanistan i brought you down to
2000 soldiers the easy part was just
getting out i brought it down from 20
000 soldiers to 2 000 soldiers the easy
part was for biden to just get them out
let the soldiers stay the remaining
soldiers and take care of everything
it's called
soldiers outlast i went to a child yeah
so very very confusing thing he says he
he got us out of iraq which he didn't he
did draw down troops in afghanistan but
then he says he left biden the easy part
but then biden should have let him stay
but it was easy to take him out it's all
very very confused it doesn't actually
make any sense trump then again telling
one of these stories of where he refers
to a taliban leader as abdul now for a
while when he said when he would refer
to this leader he would refer to him as
muhammad so it's not clear trump knows
the guy's name or maybe he's using abdul
slash muhammad as a placeholder for it
was a muslim guy it's not really clear
and he tells a story again it probably
never happened that he showed a story a
picture of the guy's house as a threat
to the leader it's very very weird
but i said abdul you're killing
ourselves jesus you better i cannot kill
ourselves
because if you do you will be
hit like no country has ever been hit
you will be hit harder than anybody has
ever been
and he said mr president but why
he actually called me your excellency i
don't know do you think he calls
biden your excellency
he goes but why your excellency mr
president
do you send me a picture of my house
[Music]
[Applause]
and i said i'd rather not answer that
question
almost certainly
never ever ever happened
trump then tells the lie that again
hillary spied on my campaign of course
the crowd demands hillary be locked up
now we know that crooked hillary
not only spied on my campaign
she spied on the white house
remember none of that is true that's not
what the durham report filing said it's
there's no evidence that that's true but
the crowd doesn't care
so the crowd chanting lock her up and of
course remember hillary clint these are
the people of law and order and due
process hillary clinton has not even
been charged never mind convicted of any
crimes locking such a person up is weird
then a really unusual contrast happened
during his riffing part because trump
does this thing during these speeches
where he'll read a little bit of
something off the prompter and then
he'll riff and in his riff he criticized
the supreme court which is one third
made up of people he selected
and then later off the prompter he
bragged about how he chose conservatives
to the court it's very funny because he
doesn't even know that this is a direct
contrast so here he is trying to go to
the audience and to booing the supreme
court justice
justices
but even our supreme court justices and
it's sad to say this right are afraid to
do what has to be done to save our
country
they're trying so desperately to be
politically correct
and to be loved by all these are the
justices of the united states supreme
court so trump there criticizing the
supreme court and what he means guys is
they didn't flip the election to him
that's really what he means but funny
later off the prompter he brags about
how he selected conservatives to the
court wait but these are the
conservatives you just attacked
ship as your president i kept my promise
and chose supreme court justices
on the list i gave to the country before
the 2016 election i gave a list of great
brilliant conservative justices
so they're now taking credit for the
great conservative justices and then
lastly and this is the funniest moment
trump starts reading his closing and
because trump struggles to read off of
the teleprompter he pauses at a weird
moment where it sounds like he's saying
i'm here today as your president trump
was actually about to read a list of
things he did as president but the crowd
is so weaponized when trump says as your
president
they think he's saying i am now your
president and they go crazy cheering and
with a standing ovation it's beyond
parody this is a sick cult in summation
and in closing as your president
i instituted
oh god
you understand what's happening right
the crowd thinks trump is saying in
summation as your president right he's
saying i'm here today as your president
and the crowd cheers remember if it's
trump alone doing these things and
nobody cares and nobody pays attention
it's one crazy guy
when you have a room full a movement
full of people who love this stuff it's
just a reminder and that's what cpac was
of how sick and dangerous and delusional
this entire movement is in the united
states that's trump's speech to cpac
let's now look at a little bit of the
sort of little press conference that
donald trump gave
i'm always looking for something new in
tech and finance something no one else
is doing and that's why i really like
masterworks one of our sponsors it's a
first of its kind fintech startup in
silicon alley in new york masterworks
gives everyday people access to
something that's usually reserved for
the ultra wealthy and that's
contemporary art as an asset class
masterworks enables you to buy
shares
that represent an investment in
world-renowned pieces of art so banksy
monet picasso right from your couch fine
art has outpaced the s p 500 by 164
percent from 1995 to 2021 and
masterworks is opening up the very
elitist art market
leveling the playing field between us
and the one percent
they analyze over 60 000 data points to
find artists with high potential for
growth they buy the art they register it
with the sec so that you can invest and
it's a way to diversify
into something with a low correlation to
the stock market i've always thought
what masterworks is doing is very cool
and they're giving my audience priority
access when you use the link below